a mighty roar went up in this auditorium  three years ago when an Oscar for Best  Performance by a leading man was handed  to our next presenter he's back tonight  to present the Supporting Actress Award  ladies and gentlemen mr. Sidney Poitier  Hey said before you begin I just want to  tell you I'm dickering for the movie  rights to the I spy series would you  like to co-star with me what part do you  want to fire  well Bill Cosby gets all the last bill  cuff gets all the girls  I'm sure we will find work as well the  five nominees for the best performance  by an actress in a supporting role are  Didion Marcia in Alfea Geraldine page in  you're a big boy now sandy Dennis and  Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf wendy  hiller in a man for all seasons and  joseline Lagaan in Hawaii  the winner is sandy Denison who's afraid  of a general accepting for sandy Dennis  Mike Nichol  sandy thank you very much I thank sandy  was nice to be up here  you